so when I first saw your book I had one
word I was like Jo get it like I can't
hang with you anymore come on like you
are so fit this is I'm gonna put this by
my treadmill and hopes that it will
motivate me yeah you know everybody's
got their own journey for sure oh my god
you know the only reason we wrote the
book was usually you get five or ten
minutes when you're doing interviews as
you know and it's usually about where
you're touring wins your tour start wins
your album coming out what's your next
single it's not how are the kids and on
that hold by the way you got in shape
how'd you do that and we got two minutes
and it never have time to really say it
all or what it does and it's really it's
much physical it was mental for me in a
lot of ways it's all it's painted having
painted you worked hard
well I'd been an athlete my entire life
I mean Ike and I come from a long ride
and athletes my dad was a professional
baseball player my uncle was a
professional baseball player so I have
some DNA in me and I was an athlete my
whole life growing up and and I kind of
let that get away from me you know being
in being on the road and being part of
that lifestyle and it's hard to like
help it's tougher but you just dig a
little deeper and find it um but uh you
know what I was going through a tough
time in my life um I lost my dad who I
was just getting to know my dad died at
59 a brain cancer and I didn't know him
growing up so I was just getting to know
him and then my stepdad passed away
another time during that time and my
grandparents and and my coach it was a
real mentor so it was a lot of loss but
but but you know in a lot of times we
fall back and use things as excuses as
well too and I was going through a thing
with my record label so you know
everything is relative to everybody you
know no matter what station in life
you're at or how much money you make or
don't make or whatever job you have
everybody has issues to deal with and
you got to find a way to deal with them
and I was dealing with him in the wrong
way and my wife told me I needed to get
my stuff together yeah and then that was
that a movie say stuff
[Laughter]
he can she can be quite colorful with
the Amish language absolutely but uh but
and then we were at a movie we took the
kids to see a movie a holiday holiday
movie and this was I guess 10 or 11
years Gracie's 22 now so she must have
been 10 or 11 years old so it was a
while back I had done a movie that I'd
sort of wanted to sort not think about
and didn't think about the trailer being
on and what net it was a bad movie or
anything like that I've seen like me but
um sure enough the first thing that
popped on the screen was the trailer of
the movie that I was in and my face on
drop on a hundred-foot screen and then
my daughter Gracie looks at me says jeez
Ted you need to do something but but to
me it was funny and she is she meant it
but she meant a lot of different ways I
think his kids pay more attention to a
lot of things in your life than we ever
realized that they pay attention to and
she meant in a lot of different ways and
it was it sort of a clarion call for me
and it wasn't a it wasn't overnight it
was a gradual process and it was you
know three steps forward and two steps
back and it always is and still and it
always will be you're never you're never
going to arrive at a goal you're always
working to get to some place but what I
found is trying to keep a physical a
consistent physical practice has helped
me find other disciplines and other
things and you know we think a
discipline is sort of this cage that you
put yourself in when you decide to apply
discipline to your life what I've
discovered is discipline really opens
the door to the cage that you're in and
it allows you to find what works you
know the stronger you build your
platform to hire you can leave and
that's what that's what I'm trying to do
and that's what I want everybody
experience and hopefully somehow if one
person gets something out of it didn't
write on I already have right by the
treadmill like it's amazing okay so how
did you I know that you went to the
physical part and you cut into kind of
helped you mentally and emotionally but
how do you do it that much lost like to
other people like because I feel like we
all experience things to be it to have a
testimony to tell other people to get
them through it as well you know for me
it you know after you sort of realized
the law so you look at what you have
and I had a lot of great things in life
I mean I had the best wife that I could
ever imagine myself having and and I got
three great daughters and and I got a
great career coming from a small town in
Louisiana where I grew up with nothing
in my life except for the love of a mom
without any and my grandparents without
that well I don't know where I would be
so to be at that place in my life have
all the things I heard possibly could
dream of in my life it made me look
around and say you know I got a lot more
to be thankful for then and to worry
about the cycle of life what a beautiful
way to turn that around yeah well you
know what's with with a Mississippi boot
in your ass do you work out with faith
that she was she works out yeah you know
she's pretty I know as the kids have
grown up we and as the kids have gotten
older we find out we're getting to spend
a little bit more time together in the
gym downstairs so I'm enjoying that for
sure I also bring your peanut buena I
didn't know that you love to cook you
and faith cook yeah we both cooked faced
a fantastic good to me I bet she can
cook everything great yeah she's a great
cook I do my I do the staples I mean we
cook some healthy a lot of healthy stuff
but we cook some stuff that's not so
healthy is well the chicken and
dumplings is a big go-to at our house
yes that's that's sort of how I hooked
faith was with chicken and dumplings
what how did he mean I took him to her
house we were to where she was we were
torn together she I didn't know her that
well and she lived right down the road
from me yeah you know I made some
chicken and dumplings I thought you know
I'll take some chicken and dumplings and
some corn right down to Faith Hill and
see how that works if it still works I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this